[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
and my answer is inevitably athletic
greens it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens comm forward slash to him that is
a great deal on one of my favorite
products and it covers my basis each day
it is part of my routine and it leaves
me with less to worry about if for
instance I have to skip a meal or just
can't get a high quality meal so check
it out go to athletic greens comm
forward slash Tim and learn all about
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty much every day either
that or the chaga which is decaf as a
separate version and I use both of these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you going let you up like
a Christmas tree so definitely check it
out people are always asking me what I
use for cognitive enhancement and for
right now this is the answer I try to
force this on all of my houseguests it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who aren't working
on projects with me I always try to feed
it to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect get a lot more out of
them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash tim and use the code tim TI m to
get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed so try them
hello ladies and germs princesses and
bridge trolls this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers to
find out what makes them tick what makes
them good and to unearth the specific
tactics habits etc that you can use and
this episode was so much fun for me and
I don't want you to take it at face
value because we get into so much in
terms of daily routine visualizing
things like weakness and anger to get
rid of them multiple steps form
mindfulness and meditation training the
mind hiring it covers so much ground so
I don't want you to be thrown off by the
fact that it starts in the cooking world
and the food world it applies to so much
more the guest is and I'm going to
butcher a lot of French in this episode
so get used to it
Eric repair r.i.p e RT who's recognized
as one of the best chefs in the world
and you'll know why in a second so in
1995 at 29 years old he earned a four
star rating from the new york times 20
years later and for the fifth
consecutive time la Bernadin which is in
new york city where eric is the chef and
co-owner once again are in the new york
times highest rating four stars becoming
the only restaurant to maintain this
superior status for such a marathon the
length of time in 1998 the James Beard
Foundation named him top chef in New
York City think about that for a minute
out of thousands of restaurants and
probably the same number of chefs and in
2003 outstanding chef of the year and it
goes on and on he's had successful TV
shows avec Eric he has hosted the show
on the table on YouTube which debuted in
July 2012 and has appeared media
worldwide he's the author of the New
York Times best-selling memoir 32 yolks
from my mother's table to working the
line avec Eric and several others now
one thing I'll point out to Eric also my
first contact with him was through
putting together my brand new book which
is tribe of mentors and if you liked
tools of Titan's you're going to love
tribe of mentors and it
similar in format but very different in
the sense that 90 plus percent of the
people in the book never appeared on the
podcast and you can learn more about
tribe of mentors on all of your favorite
book sellers websites BNN Amazon Apple
iBooks and so on and if you want to go
to for instance tim dot blog forward
slash tribe you can learn more about it
alright so that is that and really
listen to this episode we talked about
hiring and restaurants for the first
maybe thirty minutes which is still
worth listening to and then we go really
really deep on a lot of specifics that
can apply to every thing in just about
everyone so long intro but trust me it's
worth it and please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with eric
repair eric welcome to the show thank
you so much for having me very op d I
have been looking forward to connecting
with you for some time I remember first
coming across your smile on I believe it
was no reservations but it might have
been parts unknown where you took
Anthony Bourdain back on the line to see
if he had any of his any of his
endurance and skills left yeah it was
not much left actually smiling and
laughing so my idea was to torture me to
take me and and put me on the line and
see myself going down right he thought
because I was the chef of Libya now
today I forgot about how to cook on the
line and when he asked me I say oh yeah
I know I'm coming no problem but you
have to be on the line yourself and he
went down so quickly it was a great
episode and it caught me at a really
good time because I was doing research
for a book I wrote called the 4-hour
chef and I remember at the time just
before seeing that I went into his
Riverside restaurant to actually attempt
to do some prep work my knife skills are
not fantastic but there they were they
were improving and I remember watching
people on the line
and the people who are really good
seemed like they had eight arms I mean
they seemed like they were an octopus or
something along those lines and I was I
was curious just as a starting point
I've read for instance that you really
focus on mentality when you're hiring
people and that there are certain things
you can teach but mentality is very
important what makes for instance a good
line cook or what types of people do you
look for because I noticed when I was
looking at say the forearms or some of
these line cooks I mean it looked like
they've been crawling through barbed
wire and charcoal they're very very
tough and they seem to really enjoy it
almost like professional athletes also
the action of the whole thing but what
is what is the key mentality when you're
looking for someone who's going to be
good at something like that they all
become good at one point and nobody is
born with knife skills nobody knows at 3
years old how to make a sauce and so on
this is craft details of craftsmanship
and I'm not worried about the fact that
we will be able to teach the person
though the details of craftsmanship so
I'm always thinking about the mentality
of the person about if they are
potentially a good team player if they
are not a good team player
if they cannot adapt and be part of the
team I I don't like that and I will
probably not hire them because it
doesn't matter if they can multitask and
they are brilliant at what they do
at one point they would struggle during
the night or during the lunch and they
need to help also as well the other part
of the team that struggle so if they are
very individualistic and they have a
temper and they have a ego the chances
the chances are they're not coming to
live another they have to be humble they
have to be discipline and clean and this
is the obvious
being being humble is very important
because it allows you to keep yourself
couriers and motivate it if your ego is
in a way it makes you blind and you're
not inclined to learn because you
already know or you don't want to show
your weakness so those kind of things
details are what I'm looking into
someone who comes to the gang are there
and it's a lot a lot of other things I
mean obviously they have to be very
clean they have to be honest and I mean
those are of course like the ABC of
hiring someone but again being so being
a team player it's in my opinion one of
the most important thing for for someone
to become a good line cook I'm not
saying a chef I make a difference in
between a line cook and a chef a chef is
a manager and it's it's someone was the
capability of driving a team to success
and creates hopefully his own recipes
and and as many other responsibilities
in the kitchen the line cook is
basically the core of a chef it's it's
without being a great line cook without
mastering all the aspects or a lot of
the expect aspects of what's happening
in a kitchen you cannot become a good
manager or you cannot become a chef and
when you're trying to identify someone
who is a good team player do you do that
by asking certain questions do you do it
by throwing them into a shift and test
driving them and seeing how they respond
to certain situations how do you figure
out who is going to be a good team
player because I would imagine you don't
want to test it when a lot is on the
line when you have an entirely full
restaurant that's not the time to
experiment with it so how do you
determine if they're a team player or
not so first of all we look at the
resumes when they are sent to us or the
cooks
sent by a culinary school or by another
chef they have a lot of good
recommendations and what we do we invite
them to comb in our kitchen on the side
of the night
because it's a busy night and it's also
the end of the week and and we like two
of them and we don't have too many at
the same time but two or three potential
higher is in our kitchen and and we said
to them look we give you a menu and we
gonna put you in a kitchen in some
different spots and you lose you're
gonna observe and then at the end of the
night we will have a little talk with
you because what we really want is for
you to like what you see and want to be
part of that team that's working tonight
and therefore it's very light on them
they don't have any pressure they don't
have anything to do but to observe at
the same time what they don't realize is
that we are watching them as well for
instance if I see someone to our into
into the service putting his hands in
the pocket and starting to lean against
the wall and starting to yawn it's not a
good sign if I see someone starting to
bother the cooks by asking and words of
question when is the really really
difficult time of the night and and the
cooks need to be concentrated I know
that person is not it's not
understanding what's happening it's so
it's a lot of little details like that
and then at the end of the service we
sit down with them and we ask them what
they think and we and then if they have
a positive answer and they say well look
I I like your kitchen and I want to be
with you then we we go more into details
technical details of what we expect from
them and we make them come back again
and we put them in a station with
someone and they don't have any
responsibilities but they feel a little
bit of the pressure
and it's a very slow process before we
IR them do you fire quickly and we're
not going to stay on hiring and firing
the whole time don't worry but do you do
hire really slowly and fire quickly or
do you give people many different
opportunities if they make mistakes
no we don't we don't fire easily it's
very rare that we fire someone it's very
rare that someone also leaves almost
immediately after being hired because of
the process because we are slow at
hiring they understand better who we are
and they understand better if we are
good for them and therefore we don't
have to deal with those painful
consequences that are having someone
leaving or after let someone go so I'm
gonna switch gears just a little bit
well actually completely but the details
little details I love the allowing to
observe but observing them
simultaneously said I'd love to talk
about a very different type of detail
and this might be outdated but I read
about your office at one point and this
isn't this is a piece from 2005 so it
may not be accurate but could you
describe what your office looks like or
what makes your office different perhaps
then what people might think of as a
normal office and it's a leading
question so I can certainly read what I
have but I'd love for you to describe
your office if you could well my office
looks like like a monastery like a
Buddhist monastery with Buddha statues
everywhere Tonka's pictures of His
Holiness the Dalai Lama pictures of
Buddhas
mantras candles a lot of them probably
way too many and on my it's one table
that I share with my with a cat he was
my right hand and we basically face each
other and then we have another lady in
of his Chelsea was working with us for
different aspects of
the duties but I always ask them
permission and I if I can bring another
painting or another Tonka Buddha and I
asked them if they comfortable with that
if not I will remove them because I
don't want to impose on them and it's
interesting because they laugh all the
time but when I remove one Buddha they
complain about it because I'm not being
a Buddhist you not to be supposed to be
attached and obviously it's a from of
attachment and therefore I try to give
Buddha's to my friends who accept a good
happy to receive a Buddha from me
if not I moved them to to my house
although I think we are maxed out at her
house and actually it's my wife at the
funny lines of the day she said what do
you think about me bringing because
she's Catholic bringing some Christ on
the cross and putting them all over the
walls and I said yeah you're right maybe
actually move some Buddhist out of the
house as well and the two questions
image you mentioned the word and I
apologize I could make it a tonka is
that the word you used
Conchas religious paintings that I are
rolled to travel and then you put them
you put them against the wall and it's
basically usually a painting of a deity
or a Buddha that as their whole to help
you in meditation or to inspire you it
it's not just for decoration and do you
still have handwritten mantras or
mantras around the office or elsewhere
in your life well so I at home what I
have done to to avoid the discussion of
putting too many Buddha's everywhere I
have a meditation group that is
basically my world and and nobody is
telling me what to put in it or not or
not put it inside a room so I managed
that pretty well and then again the
office is a it's a work in progress what
are some of the handwritten mantras that
you ah that you have around or any-any
that are particularly important to you
that you have that you tend to revisit I
don't know I don't know I don't even
know where to begin but I'm I'm
extremely curious because I have quotes
that I put around my house for instance
one on the refrigerator one on the
coffee table because I think they're
important for me to revisit and I'm very
fascinated by this this handwritten
mantra idea well the mantras that I have
are either way in Tibetan or Sanskrit
mm-hmm but my and and I'm not sure I
understand fully the the full extent of
the power of the mantra but probably the
most powerful that I have on the world
is a mantra that explained the theory of
emptiness in in Buddhism which is
basically that nothing nothing in life
or in this world which is called samsara
as an interesting reality which means is
independent from anything else
in Buddhism we believe that everything
is a matter of cause and consequences
and everything is inter related so that
mantra is basically reminding and make
improving the point that nothing exists
by itself and we are all one if it makes
sense it is it makes more sense probably
requires a little bit of wine and a
longer conversation but no no it does
make a lot of sense to me love to rewind
the clock a little bit and we're
definitely going to come back to
meditation true certainly at at one
point but from from my understanding
perhaps it was about two decades ago
you were a very demanding chef and I
think you referred to yourself as a as a
dictator or a borderline a borderline
violent dictator yes I was and you were
losing employees could you tell us about
that period of time because that's the
last thing I would have imagined given
my exposure to you on video - given you
in writing yet I know that certainly not
very long ago that was extremely typical
in kitchens but can you tell us about
that period of time and absolutely what
changes you made or what realizations
you had yes of course I was trained in
Europe at a very young age in in
kitchens where the way to educate a cook
was through abuse and a mediation and
the belief was we gonna break we're
gonna break this person we're gonna and
then we're going to rebuild potentially
a champion
so it was allowed in a kitchen to beat
the cooks like kick them in a bird or
beat them in in a shoulder or even you
know like punching the cooks and so on
in many kitchens it was allowed and it
was common practice it was certainly
more than a common practice it was
everywhere and totally accepted to have
a chef being screaming insulting the
cooks and having tantrum in the kitchen
and throwing pans in the garbage and
plates on the floor and and it was seen
as a sign of power and I learned later
on in life that it's actually it's
embarrassing it's a huge sign of
weakness but it was it was the way many
kitchens were training their cooks in
Europe and it was actually a reflection
of the education in
sidee it was totally accepted in the
1970s when I was five years old to have
the teacher in school spanking or
smacking or pulling the ears of a
student it was totally acceptable for
parents to certainly do the same and
therefore ultimately in a work
environment we will see those kind of
abuse then when I came to the US I was
convinced that it was the right way to
maintain a kitchen maintain discipline
to create some strong people a little
bit almost like you will do with the
military's during the time of war when
you have to be training them to to be
ready to die against or to fight until
the last minute
so that was my mentality and when I
became the chef of Lebanon now even sous
chef when I was sous chef in Washington
this year the Watergate Hotel I had
those terrible tantrums in the kitchen
because the quality wouldn't be there
because the cooks were not behaving the
way I want it and I was a terror and the
waiters were scared of me and the cooks
were scared of me and I was losing the
the staff they were going to walk
somewhere else and I have I remember not
understanding why they were leaving our
I thought I was doing a good job trying
to educate them but ultimately I had to
one day sit down at home and and started
to reflect on on my life as a
professional and on my life in general
and I realized that I was miserable I
was not happy at all and I realized that
actually your brain cannot mix happiness
and anger at the same time and I can
tell you anyone can try to be happy and
angrier
the brain doesn't process that therefore
I decided
almost overnight to change the way I was
managing the kitchen the way I was
conducting my life and since then it has
been a work in progress and I'm getting
better and better and I make sure that
our kitchen is an environment where
people are happy to come and are
motivated and excited to learn what is
supposed to learn and the biggest job
that I have and and and that was at the
time is to convince my sous chefs that
yesterday we were wrong and we have to
change the sous chefs we're like what's
happening to you you completely change
and it has been a long journey for me to
convince the sous chef that the way to
educate people and to motivate people
it's being inspirational being kind
being strong and keeping a certain
discipline in the kitchen without
promoting abuse was there a particular
moment that triggered that change in you
because I imagine for instance you've
you not all the employees left at the
same time there are probably different
events different happenings was there a
particular conversation or a particular
book or a particular employee who left
that was just this straw that broke the
camel's back when you realized that
something had to change
no you know what happened it was very
interesting because I knew I was
miserable and I will close my eyes
mostly at home after work and I will try
to envision something nice something
that will make me smile or something
that would make me happy so I will close
my eyes and I would say choose something
simple envision a field of flowers or
envision a flower for instance and I was
not happy
to imagine a simple flower wow it was
all darkness and that freaked me out
that because see because you were so
angry because you know because I was in
a darkness right and that is what
triggered the change in me it was not
necessarily an employee that was fired a
certain way it was it was that moment
sitting down or laying down I don't
remember but saying oh my god I am
incapable of visualizing anything
beautiful and therefore I must be in
total darkness Wow
yeah that sounds terrifying not anymore
not anymore yeah now you now you seem
like you're able to and what what did
you say or do to convince your I suppose
through the second third and command the
sous-chefs that it was necessary and to
get them to go along with it what how
did you convince them because I can
imagine that overnight regime change you
know they're wondering if you somehow
snuck off the Burning Man for a night or
something and aren't sure what happened
how did you get them to buy in what did
you say to them yes yeah and I still
have to do that because some of them
have a temper and and some sous chefs
are joining our team and they come from
other teams that are different and and
come from a different and they were
meant that is much more abusive than at
Lebanon and so it's a constant
communication with them I basically say
look for practical results
forget forget the spiritual reason
forget being nice for the act of being
nice but for practical reason if you
scare the cook and you make him shake
and he loses cool and it cannot focus
that cook will not be productive the way
we need him to be productive and
ultimately the product that will go to
the dining room to the client will not
be as nice so on that aspect it's easy
to understand that we want the cooks not
to
scale and they have to be precise and
they have to be pushed of course because
it's it's a timing issue but they have
to be pushing a nice weight or they feel
part of the team now
the other day I had a discussion with
couple of sous chefs and and I said I
was trying to find a secular message for
them that would resonate through them in
there and that would they will
understand easily so because I always
try to not bring my Buddhist philosophy
into the kitchen except whose secular
ways so I said to them I said why don't
you treat people the way you want to be
treated and I think it's actually in the
Bible somewhere but I I told them that I
said look you like when I talk to you
nice you like when I am taking the time
and patient with you and and you like
interacting with me and knowing that I'm
a gentle soul and you don't like if I
raise my voice which is very rare and
you don't like if you see my face
looking frustrated so if you don't like
that why do you think someone else is
going to like what you do so please
treat others the way you want to be
pleased the way you want to be treated
and that really had a good impact they
understood that really well and it was a
good meeting that day and and I have to
say I mean then I believe 90% of the
time 99% of the time our kitchen is a
very good environment through blossom
but of course we have our moments of
course sometimes the challenge is so
strong that someone lose it especially
in a position of command including
myself and and in that case I have also
an antidote for that it's okay if we
lose it
and it's happening and the kitchen stops
and the cooks are terrorized or
frustrated what we have to do is we have
to wait a few minutes and or until the
end of the service and then we have to
go on the front of the entire staff and
genuinely apologize for being angry and
expressing it by potentially screaming
or any way of showing anger and I say if
we do that the cooks will will forgive
us I believe and it will also for us be
a good lesson because it's never
Pleasant to go on the front of a team
and apologize for our mistake and it's
happening now I see like some sous-chef
sometimes they lose their temper and
minutes later they go and say look I am
sorry I I apologize for my behavior and
let's let's finish the night in a better
way and even myself this week I remember
I was frustrated with the solar year who
was spending too much time at the table
explaining the wine and the food getting
cold and I called him and and I had a
couple of like rough words with him and
immediately I realized and I said you
know look I'm totally sorry but please
do not do that because our food is
getting cold
I apologize for for raising my voice I
need laughs and say take it easy it's
all good I'm a big boy but you know III
I made the effort to do that and when
you are trying to strike a balance
between say kindness and the goat the
Golden Rule that you mentioned treat
others is you would have them treat you
and extremely high quality is you've
given the examples of course it doesn't
mean that you're just running around
giving everybody hugs all night you
don't certainly give feedback what are
what are some of the approaches or
learnings that you've had in striking
that balance because when I'm as I'm
listening to you talk about your history
with sort of being brought up in a very
tough environment
was I was also coached in sports very
often in ways that were similar
extremely extremely similar particularly
during my time in Japan where they would
actually cut there's a kendo sword and
in some of the gyms I went to they would
cut off the top of the kendo swords so
that it splayed out almost and then they
would hit athletes who were training if
they did something incorrectly cut their
ears and it would cause all sorts of I
mean the Japanese are very intense that
way as well as they hurt some of their
schools of Zen meditation are also
involve a lot of physical abuse but the
point being that I had a lot of trouble
about maybe five years ago a little bit
earlier with realizing how unproductive
the anger was that I had adopted as a
way of interacting with people when I
was in a bad place and so I've I've
struggled with to be honest getting
getting better at managing people and I
think I've improved a lot in the last
few years but how have you I know that's
a lot of context but are there certain
things that you've found helpful for
finding that line of really high quality
but still returning to a place of
kindness yes I think is important to
find tools through to fight anger now
anger doesn't help to create quality
quality has nothing to do or or standout
of quality at lebanner they have nothing
to do with anger if someone does a
mistake and it doesn't realize it or
even if you realize you made a mistake
we basically bring the person to the to
the path which is the table where we
check the food and we pinpoint what's
wrong about it and we say look you made
a mistake right here and right here
go do it again and we say that really
like in a in a kind of way without
saying please go take your time and with
we said we just say go do it again but
in a nice way and we do that all night
long so it's not something exceptional
about it and the cooks have their habit
of saying yes and taking the the plate
that has a mistake on and taking and
bringing it back again the way we want
it so that that's what's happening but
it's important to time anger with the
right tools so first of all I think it's
important to analyze what anger does to
someone like for myself I realized that
anger it's something that it's a very
strong force that comes from the guts
almost and comes up it's the way I feel
it in processing anger and that's strong
there is strong force as a tremendous
power of course but that that force is
blind it's it's not a rational way it
doesn't make you rational it makes you
completely unaware of the consequences
of what that force makes you do so for
instance you may very well insult
someone like you mentioned in Japan the
bit people in some with so much leads or
something like that if it comes from
anger it's not it's impossible to
control and and you don't the
consequences are basically negative
obviously and then when when you come
down and when the anger is God suddenly
you like wow why what did I do
my god it was not necessary so analyzing
that or making that exercise of
contemplation - well someone was angered
or to yourself
it's important and then
I use the tool of meditation for anger
very often and for instance a very easy
meditation for anyone at home is to
visualize anger as a as a dark cloud
coming out of yourself and imagining a
laser coming out of your forehead and
destroying the dark cloud and if you do
that
every day thinking that the anger is a
dark cloud I can guarantee you that one
day the anger is coming and you have the
almost like this Pavlov reflex of saying
oh my god is the dark cloud and instead
of letting anger go and and and blind
you you destroy that anger and would you
suggest them doing this visualization
this meditation say in the morning or is
it is it a tool that they use whenever
they start to sense the physical
symptoms of anger or both
well yeah it's both because I believe
that when you do meditation it's better
to do it on a morning because your mind
is clear usually or clearer you don't
have all the all the distraction of the
day all the actions that you have done
that will potentially potentially
distract you during your meditation
morning meditations are in my opinion
much more productive and and then when
you like I mentioned before when you get
angry
after many meditations on on that dark
cloud again you remember this when you
apply it what what does your current
meditation practice look like and we can
definitely get into the details on this
podcast it's just been fascinating in
the last few years to see that of all of
the people I interview who operate at a
high level in any field I would say
more than 85% have some type of
mindfulness practice or meditation
practice and it takes many many
different forms but I'd love to hear
specifically what your meditation
practice looks like what time you do it
in the morning if you could just walk us
through yes in the case of a morning
meditation what is what are the first
sort of 60 minutes or an hour of your
day look like us those are the same I
guess 60 minutes or 90 minutes of the
day look like for you I like to have my
day it's a very it is very repetitive
it's like the pattern I follow a pattern
so I wake up and I frost myself because
I always forget to be grateful to be
alive
and then what time do you typically wake
up six o clock 6:30 7 o clock if I
rarely 8 o clock I mean it's yeah I mean
for me it's pretty early after that I
look at my phone I quickly look at the
news on the phone messages and things
like that but it doesn't take too much
after that I go make my coffee then I go
to my meditation room and I do some
rituals Buddhist rituals I make some
offerings I read a little bit I say some
mantras and then I start my meditation
and when I start the meditation I don't
even sit in a lotus position because I
find it a distraction for me because my
knees hurt and my back hurt and I'm not
that flexible so therefore I sit I sit
straight but comforta comfortable and I
start to look at the room and and I look
at the details of the room and then I
close my eyes and I do what we call
schemata schemata meditation is
basically
being in the present and controlling
your mind and not letting the mind think
about the past or think about the future
or start to be judgmental
we call that avoiding a monkey mind
monkey mind is when you you're not in
control of your mind but your mind is in
control of yourself that exercise can be
done by focusing on the way you inspire
and excel many people do that for myself
it's a little bit different when I
inhale I feel the energy coming from the
first chakra which is the chakra is
basically the middle of your boat and
and the energy going up to the seventh
chakra which is on top of the head right
and then when I I exhale the energy goes
down it looks like it's almost like a
tube in my back that carried the energy
up and carried a remnant energy down so
I do that for a few minutes and I don't
count the minutes because I don't want
to be distracted by oh my god I mean II
mean am I going to do time in it or am I
going to - only five minutes today or
what am I going to do so I I don't put
pressure on myself what is important is
not the quantity in terms of timing it's
the quality then when I feel that I am
really the present and in control of my
mind I decide we I decide which
meditation I'm going to do very often
they are meditation that are linked to
Buddhism but sometimes it can be a
meditation that is universal and secular
like for instance visualizing a weakness
and and finding a way to destroy that
weakness so it can be anger it can be
jealous
see it can be attachment you can be
designed anything but I always end up by
doing the 12 link meditation which is
typically a Buddhist meditation from the
Vajrayana school which is Buddha a
Tibetan Buddhist 12 link Li NK
it and how and I know you're not
carrying the minutes but typically how
long do you do that for it probably
takes about all - in between schemata
and Vibhishana which is guided
meditation and schemata being single
point meditation is when you basically
control your brain and then is when you
with your brain concentrate on different
subjects in between both meditations
must be about 25 minutes half hour
maximum not more than that then I read
again and then sometimes I meditate
again if I have time but that's
basically the about two hours of my time
on the rolling is in between doing the
ritual that ayah that I just explained
to you I have quite a few questions
about this because I love the details
and my listeners love the details and
I'm also about to do my first silent
retreat for 10 days so I'm thinking oh I
don't think I'm thinking a lot about
this I think it's I think it's part of
the medicine I need we all need
something I think this is part of what I
need and I'm gonna get to the meditation
in in in detail but just for people who
may not have ever experienced something
like this or attempted anything like
this what are some of the benefits that
you see from this or perhaps a different
way to answer it would be what were you
like before this type of practice and
how are you different now meditation
ultimately help you to train your mind
how to concentrate in a better way
helps you to control like I mentioned
before your mind if not the mind is
something that is very free and very
lack discipline and so it's it's it's
the only only way for you to be in
control of yourself and it's the best
way for yourself to concentrate and
through if you are studying some
philosophical subjects to go to the
roots of the subjects that's what
meditation does it also I believe help
you to be Calmar it's gotta be of an
English world I don't think so
kamar Carl yes sorry calm Eric okay to
be yet to be much more serious but it
this way mm-hmm and it doesn't happen
overnight
and meditation very often on the
beginning it's frustrating and it's it's
not leisure fool it's a challenge but
then after a lot of practice it becomes
honest necessity it becomes kind of a
refuse for yourself and it's it's a lot
of pleasure coming out of it I I'm gonna
I really appreciate that and I'm gonna
come back to I also for people who are
listening in or just like oh my god we
will meditation Buddhism like saved me
because I know a lot of type-a
personalities do that which is what I
did not too too long ago I remember I
was listening to someone being
interviewed on stage who used to have a
lot of anger issues and they seem to
have resolved a lot of them through
meditation and somebody asked them how
long they meditate and they said well
usually it's about 30 minutes and they
said oh I could never sit still for 30
minutes and they said well if you if you
can't meditate for 30 minutes you need
three hours generally the harder it is
for you the more you need it in but
going back to the beginning of your day
I'd love to and hopefully this is
irritating for you but just to go
through each of these and ask a few
questions so the grateful to be alive is
that something you say to yourself is
that a feeling is it just listening to
the world around you what exactly do you
do when you wake up and remind yourself
of that so I wake up and when the when
my mind wakes up it's not like like I am
confused I know where I am I am in my
bed I am aware of that I have this sense
of awareness but I try to have my first
thoughts dedicated to the fact that I am
alive and I'm lucky to be alive because
it gives me many possibilities to be a
better person to have an impact on other
people to also a good day on the front
of me and so on so it's something that
I'm I'm doing right away
and it's not like I'm thinking about it
for 10 minutes it's a very quick thought
it's few seconds thinking about it and
say wow I'm lucky thank you
I'm appreciating the fact that I'm
waking up today and I am Alive mm-hmm so
the next thing you do
I was actually fascinated that you drink
coffee before you meditate which is not
necessarily a bad thing I've just
actually never come across it with an
experienced meditator yet I'm sure that
you're not the only one what type just
because I have to ask since you have so
much culinary expertise what is your
go-to coffee how do you what type of
coffee how do you make it so first of
all it's decaf coffee and that helps me
I guess a lot for my meditation and I'm
not in charge of buying the coffee if my
wife goes to the store and and buys
quality coffee from different countries
but she she knows my tests after so many
years and I don't know where it's coming
from but it always tastes the same so I
cannot I cannot tell you do you use a
machine do you use Chemex do you have
any particular I know this is getting
nerdy but I'm wondering if it's like
super simple actually no some from some
really really good chefs who love
instant coffee and then I know some who
will do a 10-minute pour over and hand
grind the beans and do all of that so
where are you in that spectrum the beads
are I am dry grind like you mentioned
I'm using a mr. coffee machine you know
the coffee comes very hot and I don't
like hot coffee but it gives me the time
to sit down and let my coffee get
slightly cooler and it's away from you
also to like start my day in a very
quiet simple way and I I wait a few
minutes for the coffee to to be a bit
warmer and then then and then I text me
about at least 15 minutes to drink my
cup of coffee actually it's a mug but it
takes me about 15 minutes and really the
coffee for me becomes very pleasurable
in terms of temperature in the last five
minutes of the process I like that I
like that you it's you deliberately have
coffee that's too hot because you can't
rush and you you then go into your
meditation room you make some offerings
yes
which which maybe we can we can do in a
part to podcast because I I want to talk
about the reading what what do you read
because it you you do the offering you
read then you have mantras then
meditation and then you also read
as a bookend at the end of the session
what are you reading or what do you like
to read I mostly read Buddhist texts
books from masters or ancient masters
and from modern teachers and mostly
teachings from His Holiness the Dalai
Lama that's what I read are there any
particular chapters or books that you
would recommend to someone if they
wanted to start somewhere
oh yeah of course you have always liked
Buddhism for dummies but I don't
recommend it it's I think studying the
Four Noble Truths with someone like the
Dalai Lama it's a good idea because it's
a very interesting and simple approach
to Buddhism it's the realization that so
the fundamentals basically are the was
the first teaching of Buddha after he
got enlightened and is the realization
that in life at one point another life
is made of suffering and that suffering
so does that's the first truth the
second truth is that suffering has an
origin so basically that suppose you
have a big headache and where is the
headache coming from a suffering maybe
last night you had a bit too much
tequila it could be right I mean I'm
trying to be funny with that but yeah
it's to identify the root of suffering
because suffering cannot exist by itself
without a previous condition then it's
to say well if I don't want to have that
suffering again
I have to stop creating the conditions
that leads to that suffering so that's
the third noble truth and the fourth
noble truth is the path of liberation
from suffering which is basically
following the teaching of Buddha and the
path of liberation is very simple to use
you can draw a circle and it's called
the eight fold path I think it's eight
fold in English path of liberation so
basically it's eight recommendation from
Buddha which are very very simple
because again was his first teaching and
not necessarily to some people where
they are knowledgeable in Buddhism so
the first thing to say to yourself is I
trust the teaching of Buddha and I will
question every everything about the
teaching but if it makes sense to me I
will trust the teaching and and study
the second thing is to say to yourself
while studying is not good enough I have
to practice having good thoughts during
my journey then adding a good speech
therefore adding good actions then it's
adding a job that is not it's not in
contradiction with the teaching of
Buddha you cannot be in a mafia and kill
people and be a Buddhist it doesn't work
and then it's to say well I'm gonna to
the right efforts every day to implement
all of the above and become a better
person and that needs to say well I'm
gonna practice concentration to be able
to achieve that goal because it requires
a lot of concentration
and then it's to achieve wisdom and use
that wisdom for good reasons so this is
the Four Noble Truths thank you very
much for that and I'd loved you
maybe it's within the context of those
truths and trying to follow the stress
or not I don't know but in your process
where you do offerings reading mantras
are the mantras in English or in another
language or in French or otherwise know
the mantras are in Sanskrit or in
Tibetan sometimes but for instance the
mantra of empty of emptiness I can tell
you now and I don't think you gotta
understand much and and I'm not sure I
understand fully the mantra but that
eotteon got I got a pair I got a
parasamgate Bodhi surah so I say that
mantra many many times I have a man la
which is basically like a bracelet with
pearls little pearls and you have 108
pearls each of them representing the
teaching of Buddha and if you repeat
that and read an eight times if you have
the time to do it if not you do it three
times and and you try to understand the
mantra like for instance emptiness is
it's a very very important part of
Buddhism that explain all phenomenons of
life and I can i I mean we can go into
details of it if you want but it's going
to take an hour
well given given the time constraints we
have today very quickly let's you know
for instance you can you can have a page
of paper on the front of you and it is a
page of paper do not deny the fact that
it is a page of paper now for you it's a
page of paper but
for someone else who doesn't was never
seen a page of paper it could be
something to like the fire or it could
be some other interpretation so whatever
you you think of is not necessarily the
ultimate truth it's just your
interpretation also that sheet of paper
that that page that all you have on the
front of you is made of wood that was
once a seed in the ground that became a
tree after years of rain and wind and
and and Sun and nights that piece of
paper if you go further is made of
particles atoms and smaller particles
and ultimately the piece of paper that
you have on the front of you is yes a
piece of paper but it's much more than
that you and I have a lot to talk about
my friend thank you I mean I'm I'm a
student trying to explain to you what I
understand I am NOT definitely not
considering myself a teacher well
speaking of teachers just just and then
I'm going to keep zooming in and out I'm
gonna come back to visualizing weakness
because I'd love to get a real-world
example from you of a weakness you were
working on and what you did but before
we get there just as perhaps a
jumping-off point for people who are
curious about this so there are few
books I I grew up with a very strong
aversion to religion of all types or
anything I considered organized religion
and we don't have time to psychoanalyze
that right now but suffice to say that
that that is something I have carried
for a very long time so I had a visceral
knee-jerk resistance to anything that
almost anything that had an ism at the
end of it if that makes sense and then
there were a few books that were
introduced to me that had a tremendous
impact and maybe thinkers is another way
to put it
so the the first was from I don't know
how I came across it but it was a book
written by tick not Han was nominated
for the Nobel Peace Prize by dr. Martin
Luther King jr. yes exactly and it was
either it was one of the two because I
ended up reading both but the miracle of
mindfulness or pieces every step and I
remember there was there was one example
not to make this about me but it might
be helpful to people out there one
example and I don't know which book it
was in it was when one of the two that
really stuck with me for decades now is
he talked about how and this is an
example of how mindfulness can actually
help you right at least in my mind I was
like oh wow that actually makes perfect
sense and it was if you're if you're
washing the dishes after a meal and
you're going to reward yourself with I
think it was a plum and the whole time
you're washing the dishes you're
thinking about the plum you're thinking
about the plum when you eat the plum
you're not going to enjoy the plum
because you'll be thinking about
whatever's coming after the plum and I
was like oh my god that's so simple but
it makes a lot of sense that cross it
take that hunt and then also Tara brach
wrote a book called radical acceptance
it's it's a very boring title but it it
is one of the things that perhaps more
than anything else particularly after my
first real television experience which
was very very difficult on everyone it
was a suicide mission of sorts I mean
the the schedule everything was
extremely extremely difficult and I I
lost my temper a few times at not
generally people in the field but
usually with editing team and I was very
ashamed of that very I'm proud of that
and this book really helped me to I
think radical acceptance reconcile a lot
of what was just dying at me on the
inside or causing that to come out at
really bad times and I bring up those
books because when you and I have had
some interaction electronically and
I'm very excited to have you in in the
new book that's coming out not not too
far out tribe of mentors so thank you
for that Sharon Salzberg and a bunch of
really wonderful people are in there
you mentioned the dalai lama's 100
elephants on a blade of grass and you
also the French which I'm not going to
try to pronounce because it'll sound
terrible when I try it but was with that
you were was that the book that made the
difference for you in terms of exploring
these types of subjects or was there
something that you found first and how
did you find the book no it was this
book for sure and I still have the book
of course which is out of trains because
it's from 1989 that book was sent to me
by my mother I was living in Washington
DC and I had previously booked read a
book in a plane coming to America to
live permanently in America a book about
Tibet and about Buddhism and I was
interested but I was a bit confused but
it was something was interesting about
it how did you find that first book so I
was a direct product and this was in
France I was yes I was about to go into
the into the plane and I had 10 francs
which is the equivalent of $2 or bitless
and I mean francs do not exist anymore
now is euros but at the time it was
about that much and I was tempted to buy
playboy natural healthy young man and I
actually went and grabbed the Playboy
and then I said that book about Tibet
that was that was somewhere in the in in
the airport and and I look at it it was
the same price and I said oh my god I'm
interested because I always was curious
about Tibet it looks like it's it's we
don't know much about that country and
so on so I said I'm gonna buy the Tibet
Tibetan book and then I got the book and
then
I went back to the Playboy and I dropped
the book and then I was paying for the
Playboy and I that at the last second I
said to delayed you know please I'm
sorry I I'm I'm taking the book and I
put back the Playboy in where we belong
and that was my first interest in
Buddhism and and in Tibetan culture it's
hard it's hard to make proper use of a
Playboy on an airplane so I interrupted
them so you read that book and then your
mother sent you yes I said to where I
said look can you try to find me
something interesting about Buddhism and
Tibet and maybe it's it's someone master
was I didn't know the Dalai Lama at the
time I had no idea and she find that
book and sent it to me and in the in the
beginning of the book is the speech that
he made when he got the Nobel the peace
Nobel Prize and that speech really moved
me tremendously it was a brilliant
brilliant compassionate speech that he
made and after that I read of course the
rest of the book which touch different
aspect of Buddhism but ultimately I
understood that Buddhism can be three
things at the same time and it's wide so
it's so appealing today to a lot of
people because Buddhists can be a
religion if you wish we can be also
purely a philosophy and it can be also
although the theory of Buddhism can be
proven by science especially quantum
physic or quantum mechanics so you have
three ways to embrace the fields of your
Buddhism one being totally secular and I
think it's actually probably the future
of Buddhism is to be proven by science
in quantum mechanics is is the best way
to to prove the theory
or philosophically by by debating and by
analyzing you can prove the theory of
the many theories of Buddhism and then
of course you can always follow the
religious parse path which it's not in
is it's not fighting the the fact that
it is it's a science and it's a
philosophy as well it's just
complementary and some people are purely
religious some people are purely
scientific about it and some people are
doing are using the the three aspects of
that philosophy one thing that also
brought me back into the orbit of
Buddhism and I wouldn't call myself a
Buddhist in the same way that people are
like oh are you a surfer I'm like no no
I said I surf very very poorly but I
would never call myself a surfer
wouldn't self identify that way I'm very
interested in reading different books on
say Buddhism but mostly in the secular
capacity and yeah and in part because a
branch of philosophy called stoicism I
can effectively say save my life and on
at least one occasion probably more one
of the quotes I have on my refrigerators
from Marcus Aurelius
so the stoic thinkers particularly
epictetus Seneca and Marcus Aurelius the
most famous book by the last being
meditations have a lot of overlap with
secular Buddhism they're very they're
almost entirely compatible I can't think
of one thing that comes to mind that is
contradictory and so the so the Greeks
and the Romans brought me back to
Buddhism to expand my
thinking about how to become more
self-aware and less emotionally reactive
and there's there's very well shouldn't
say very little but if we're looking at
secular stoicism because you can get
into cosmology and some really weird
stuff then the there there isn't a there
isn't a ton to work with in terms of
original texts and butum Haslam has a
lot more to work with in terms of
original writings over many many
centuries and different cultures also
which is interesting to me to look at
the different breeds so to speak but
what I've noticed in Silicon Valley is
that both stoicism and Buddhism here I'm
sitting in San Francisco become more
popular because I think in part you can
take engineers who may be by default
more secular and give them a tool kit to
help with navigating life and I was
having a conversation with a gentleman
named Jerry Kelowna who in a former life
a very very successful technology
investor among other things and now
works with executives that a lot of the
technology companies that people would
recognize and one of the questions that
he likes to ask which is perfectly you
don't have to be a Buddhist to ask this
type of question but it happens to
relate is and I'm gonna paraphrase here
but how are you complicit in creating
the conditions you say you don't want
alright so how are you contributing to
creating the conditions that you say you
don't want which seems to come right
back to the Noble Truths and so on that
you were talking about but the the
weakness visualizing weakness is very
interesting to me so I want to make sure
I come back to that briefly we can
bounce around certainly but when you're
going through your meditation and you're
visualizing weakness can you give us an
example of a weakness past or current
that you've visualized and what that
process looks like in your mind hmm yes
before I go to that I'd like to say one
thing that is
very interesting to me about Buddhism is
that it's not a not dogmatic religion or
philosophy at all and actually even
Buddha himself Buddha means basically
the enlightened one right but but his
name was Shakyamuni Shakyamuni himself
say please please please please it's not
because I am respected and I am
supposedly enlightened that you should
take every word I say for truthful
please analyze everything I say and
reject everything that doesn't make
sense
in my in my speech in my actions in my
theories do not take the dogma as it is
question everything and and today when
you study Buddhism your teachers they
they very very articulate in making sure
that you do that and they test you
making sure that you do not know do not
accept anything they say because they
are supposedly
your teacher or supposedly pure or
anything like that so that's very
interesting to me that you have to
reject whatever doesn't make sense to
yourself now going back to the weakness
weakness are coming from ignorance and
ignorance is basically the root of all
weaknesses and it's we basically
consider in Buddhism three boys on of of
the mind which are coming from ignorance
one of the the first one is attachment
and anele anele see desire and then
hangar is a anger is very powerful
poison of the mind as well and that
comes from ignorance so let's say
attachment let's take the the subject of
attachment so I could be attached to
many things and I am during the day
actually I mean
the man who's talking to you right now
is Eric repair is a simple man who's
trying to be a good guy and will fail
many times in his vision I'm not talking
to you as a master here and I'm a
student I'm trying every day to to fight
anger to fight attachment and ignorance
so therefore saying that if I take
attachment as a subject I'm trying to
see where I am attached the most is it
the power is it the glory is it the
money is it something else
and then I decide that today I'm going
to focus on the fact that I'm attached
to my reputation as a great chef and I'm
very potentially that can bring to a
very insecure reaction to were on that
and I can be very attached so so much
attached to my reputation of a four-star
chef and sauce mr. chef Michelin our
international [ __ ] whatever it is and
that it's definitely something that is
negative so when I identify the subject
that I want to fight I basically
concentrate and say why are you so
attached to be someone of the potential
like being a celebrity for instance why
what does it do what is it what does it
do for you what is how good is it for
you what what happen if you lose that
what what will be the consequence of
losing that and and how important is it
in your life compared to being LC and
and being a compassionate person and and
so on and and when you analyze the
subject you realize that
suddenly if you attach to your title
which actually when you actually die
stays here and you die and your title is
doesn't exist anymore so it's not even
meaning foolin on the long term when I
identify that that weakness which is an
attachment for in in this instance I say
okay well I'm going to visualize because
I want to make it simple for my mind to
fight I'm gonna visualize that as
something and from it I mean for you
could be something else but it could be
a rock a stone
it could be anything for me I always go
to the dark cloud because for some
reason it works in my mind I see a dark
cloud and I'm like this dark cloud is my
attachment to my title and to what I
supposed to represent and I am going to
get rid of it and I have decided that
probably because I read a lot of how you
called books from style I mean what Star
Wars and and and and read a lot of comic
books and so on
so I I am the the guy was the laser on
the front of the in his forehead I have
that power of destroying that cloud and
saying well that cloud is full of
attachment to something that is not
meaning food at the end of the day at
the end of the day it it's not it's not
important and I'm destroying and I'm
destroying and destroying and destroying
and doing that repetitively create
basically like I said before like the
puzzle of reflex goodness I'm gonna have
doubt about losing what I have built in
terms of reputation I'm gonna think
about is it really important in my life
can I can I give it a
and and I realized that it is not
important to me in my life and I can
give it away easily and then suddenly
boom the cloud is I visualize the cloud
and I destroy it and I don't have I
don't have that fear anymore of losing
of being attached that's that's my way
of doing it I'm not sure it's the
perfect way and I'm not sure it works
for everybody but for me it's the way I
do it and it's very simple when you
think about it so simplicity in and
maybe simplicity's in the right word
maybe elegance is the right word in
terms of few moving pieces but very very
high quality pieces is actually what I
think of when I hear your name and you
know I'm sure that as with any high-end
operation speaking of your restaurant
restaurants that you know maybe it's
like the duck on the surface where it's
extremely calm and then you don't see
that the feet kicking like hell
underneath I don't know but the the the
question I wanted to ask you is related
to attachment so many people in the
culinary world are attached to and this
is true everywhere but money and growth
and particularly with the profile that
you have you must get approached to do
huge chains and dozens of this and
hundreds of that you you must be sent
opportunities like that all the time I
mean I would imagine it has to happen
every week how have you thought about
making decisions about sort of quality
versus scale yes well I am not naive I
mean I am not that naive and I
understand the benefits of being wealthy
that comes usually from working out and
developing businesses and so on
or sometimes you come from from some
other directions but wealth definitely
contributed to happiness but ultimately
we know it doesn't bring happiness and
inner strength in your happiness so you
have to I mean in my case I decided that
I had to find my level of contentment
and what was my level of contentment so
I I created it and I said look my level
of contentment is that I have a very
sexual restaurant in New York that makes
me very happy that creates jobs 460
families and we work as a team to make
our clients happy to create experiences
for people who come here and we live
from that and now I live pretty well and
I'm trying to give a good lifestyle and
good income to everyone within the
company of course in relative to their
position and to the responsibility that
they have I mean not everybody has the
same compensations but I think like that
and then I look at my life and I'm like
you know I'm very lucky in this life
first of all so far I think I am Elsie
[Music]
I'm not starving not in a war I have a
happy family surrounding me supporting
me I have a team that seems to like me
and and in terms of money I
I eat well I am travelling when I need
to travel I have the pair of sneakers
that I like I have a pair of jeans I
have a t-shirt I have what it's called I
have
sweaters and so on how many of that do I
need how many houses do I need how much
money do I need in a bank and when I'm
gonna leave this world everything is
gonna stay here I'm not taking anything
with me so how much sacrifices I have to
make to accumulate wealth that are worth
worth it or not
and I realized that for myself look
beyond out there and we have another
restaurant in Cayman Island with the
ritz-carlton called blue by Eric repair
and I'm consulting there but it's very
low maintenance for me it's it's mostly
the team the teams both teams that work
together with my mentorship but I said
to myself look if you open another
restaurant in Vegas and one in Dubai and
one in Hong Kong Singapore whatever and
accept accept all those those offers
suddenly your lifestyle is going to
change you're not gonna have time for
yourself which I need as you can
understand in a previous discussion we
had you realize that I need a lot of
time for myself
and I believe that time is for myself as
positive consequences on my family and a
better family member and the family
support me and support my business and
the business support my family so I kind
of have other that balance that I'd
really don't wanna change I'm content
and I don't want to lose I don't want to
lose that and it's not about being
attached to that it's not enough it's
not an healthy attachment it's just that
it's very beneficial for myself first of
course but for everyone around me and
it's why it's why
I am where I am and I'm doing what I'm
doing I mean you sound content and not
that I have a perfect radar for that but
I mean some mornings I'm a bit more
grumpy for the coffee but I have
challenges during the day I mean it's
not like my days are blissful or every
day of the week I have some challenges
that I have to resolve and I have some
moments of stress and so on I mean it's
not like you know Nirvana here it's it's
New York
that is a great quote
I want to if you'd be comfortable
because I think it would be very
encouraging for a lot of people
listening if you're willing to look back
at your childhood it seems like
certainly at points it was very
difficult for you could you tell us
about some of those early days maybe
just describe for us some of yes what
your childhood was like and some of the
most sort of important events in your
childhood so I was born in a family that
was pretty successful my mother was in
the fashion industry she was a still a
beautiful woman
my father was in banking perfect young
couple a success story they were living
in the French Riviera they were actually
at living when I was four or five years
old in San Tropez so it was you know
with the jet-set and so on and then they
divorced and my life change with the
divorce until then I was and when they
divorce I was about six years old or
five five six years old until then I had
a great life everything was fine and
then when they divorced my mother
remarried my father remarried is his
wife didn't necessarily like my presence
my stepfather was very very mean to me
at least is the way I felt and it was
hell at home for me as a young kid I was
sent when I was eight years old to
boarding school where it became hellish
when a priest tried to sexually abuse me
many challenges like that in my life
then I came back home of course and I
had to deal with my stepfather for a
long time it was very challenging
relationship that we had it was verbally
abusive and physically will have no
problem to beat me and and so on of
course making sure that my mother
wouldn't know my mother was struggling
to to raise me and at 15 being a very
bad student and having a lot of anger
issues and a lot of other issues linked
to that lifestyle I was at 15 years old
in a principal office at the end of the
year nine nine grade discussing my
future and my future was it cannot go to
a regular school is erica's to find a
job and I was actually very happy about
that because I didn't like the the
school system and I asked if I could go
to culinary school and learn the
craftsmanship of becoming a chef it was
not easy
culinary schools are very difficult and
they require a lot of discipline and
it's it's it's tough for young kids like
when they are 15 years old 16 years old
17 17 actually I moved to Paris and I
lived in tiny tiny tiny apartment that
worked in the Torah which was the
famous at the time and and struggle with
ridiculous salaries and and the
challenges of the kitchen and so on and
those years where we're not happy earth
for myself moving on I mean I work for
Joelle Robbie show in his kitchen they
were tough kitchens a lot of work not
too many rewards that you will see at
the end of the day and when I was I
think why I did my military duties
because they were mandatory and it's not
really a pleasant experience it's not
meant to be a pleasant experience then I
moved to the u.s. in 1989 without
speaking a world of English so huge
challenges coming to America and
discovering that nobody's waiting for
you are they have brought with the red
carpets and say you know to cook your
genius in New York City all those
aspects were very very challenging and
didn't make me a happy camper and I was
I was missing something in my life I was
missing
spirituality and and what Buddhism kept
from me today but yes I was I was a
little bit lost and angry and angry
means unhappy that was really the
beginning of my life
of course I had some good moments and
and some good friends and good
relationships and and so on but when I
look at the big picture of they were on
the dark dark here when did you during
that entire period was there a
particular moment or day or dish or
anything where you realized huh I think
I could actually be really good at this
meaning cooking was there any assignment
teacher anything that gave you the
confidence it's interesting
because I started in 1991 at Leonarda as
the chef and in 94 I was the executive
chef of Lebanon and and the business
partner of Magilla cause who created
with her brother Olivia nada 1991 90 90
for the brother passed away and I was in
charge of the kitchen by myself I mean
by myself with the team of course to
manage the team and in 1995 who's Rachel
the New York Times gave gave the team
and to myself
ultimately the four star review and from
there we had only accolades and rewards
and and so on
but I never thought I was a good cook
neither a good chef and it took me until
the year 2000 when I did a book called
return to cooking that I realized that I
was insulting my luck because I was
talented and not everybody's talented
and I had to acknowledge it without
being pretentious not to insult my luck
it was a discovery for me so a return to
cooking was an adventure I wanted to
study the Four Seasons a little bit like
this I'll give with the music but myself
with the food and I decided to bring a
painter to photographer and a writer and
to go to different regions of America
during different seasons and therefore
we rented houses in Vermont for the fall
in Hamptons for the summer in the spring
in California and because the winter was
too challenging in North America we
decided to go to Puerto Rico and during
that experience that was starting every
morning with for the painter a black
canvas and for myself going to the
market and finding ingredients and
cooking for the group and documenting
the recipes and so
it's when I realize that I was a good
cook
mm mm mm it's amazing it it took me such
a long time and then after that I have
been making sure that it doesn't go to
my head and that I stay humble and that
I share the knowledge and the cooking
wisdom accumulated and and yeah it's
it's what it is but ultimately since
that process I accept the gift that I
received in my life which is being able
to be a good cook and to be a chef
ultimately you have you have also your
memoir which is 32 yolks yes subtitle
from my mother's table to work in a lion
and I wanted to ask you because it's it
seems like you have a very special
relationship with your mother if you're
cooking dinner for your mother are there
any particular meals that you like to
make for her or that she likes you to
make for her I think she likes to cook
for me ah that's I thought I should have
seen that coming yes no that's that
makes sense it's very interesting
because when I was a kid and she knew I
was a nappy and I was challenged way to
make me happy and to to show our love to
our son was through the process of
feeding me through the process of
cooking for me is where she put all of
her energy as a mother and I I will feel
it I will know it was meant to be
a proof of love for our child
and if today I am with my mother I am
sure that she will net not let me take
the knife and and start to slice
vegetables or anything she would take
total control of the kitchen claiming
that I will mess up the kitchen and she
would have to clean it after so that
will be our excuse but
I think the real result will be to make
her son
feeling the love from his mom I have
many dishes that I love from her she was
doing and she still does Vietnamese
spring roll called nem which I loved
actually I have never been able to make
it as good as hers and she will make
also for mr. cope well with green
peppercorn sauce that was for me like
the ultimate and then every day she will
make an apple tart that was like what 12
inches apple tart that I will eat every
afternoon when I was coming back from
school and that was that was my figure
with me man I'm so hungry I've been in
fact I've been fasting I'm so hungry I'm
like salivating like my dog when I'm
opening a can of food is it true this is
just I guess in the in the questions
related to food category is it true that
you eat Swiss cheese before you taste
dishes oh yes okay can you explain this
please yes of course not only is Swiss
cheese I make the entire team of sous
chefs and they are eight through chefs
in in Lebanon then I make them eat Swiss
cheese that is not artisanal is it is an
industry old cheese because it always
has the same flavor it's it's very
consistent it's not the best Swiss
cheese it does it doesn't have the
qualities of an artisanal cheese but we
know that it tastes a certain way and
then we when we come to the kitchen we
caliber our palate by testing it so when
I say caliber our palate what I mean is
that if I test the cheese today and it
tastes too salty I know my palate is
very sensitive to salt the cheese
test very bland my palate is known if
the cheese tastes very well-balanced I
know my palate is very accurate and we
we do that with all the sous chefs we
are going to go to all the Mazon class
which is the preparation from different
stations and when we go test the sauce
and and any preparation if we find
everything salty we know it's because
our palate is off because of the cheese
gave us the information that we we are
ultra sensitive to salt or if everything
seems to be bland I know my palate is is
numb and that can come from many things
I mean if you drink a bit too much at
night your palate will be numb if you if
you have a good diet and and and don't
eat too many sweets at night and you
depending on your lifestyle and what you
eat your palate will react the day after
and and the cheese is the way for us to
to know that I love that are all right
so a few since that one mind some some
gold I'm gonna keep going with some food
related questions if if you could ask
home cooks just assume most people are
listening of course home cooks one
ingredient they should use less and one
ingredient you wish they would
experiment with more I am in favor of
organic and we gotta take two examples
right we're gonna take animals and and
we gotta take vegetables so if you have
the choice of feeding your family an
animal like a chicken for instance or
eggs or even milk that doesn't have
growing hormones doesn't have pesticides
doesn't have antibiotics
and so on if you have that choice would
you give your child the meat or eggs on
me or milk with those chemicals in it or
would you give your child and if you can
afford it obviously because very often
is a matter of budget but will you give
your child a product that is purely
natural and doesn't have those chemicals
for the vegetables is very much the same
I'm not anti GMO vegetables necessarily
but when GMO carried he carried the it's
not the genes but the DNA of roundup for
instance and when the vegetables are a
lot of pesticides and and so on and when
you have choice and you can give to your
family vegetables of fruits we don't
have that what will you give to your
family so I think my answer is not
exactly what you expect because you
would like to maybe one single
ingredient but I'm a bit broader in my
vision and I think it's still important
to not necessarily answer what you want
it sure creative Liberty here but if we
go to an ingredient I would say if you
have choice in between real butter and
fake butter right that is made of
chemicals and so on processed foods
basically it's processed food if you
have the choice use the regular butter
for instance which as we know it as fat
it has benefits and it has ingredient in
in in its body that are not necessarily
positive for the human body but do not
use processed food the body
however body doesn't digest processed
food easily or doesn't digestion at all
so I'm saying use natural products good
recommendation I yeah the budget I
really wish that there were more of a
level playing field I'm optimistic about
Amazon having bought Whole Foods I'm
very very interested to see how that may
open the door to since the first one of
the first announcements they made was
going to be lowering prices since in
effect Amazon's creating an internal
customer for developing their own
infrastructure potentially to then
supply food on a much broader scale so
they can afford to have lower prices I'm
very very excited to see how that
impacts get me to the options that
people have do you have a favorite
cocktail dirty martini with dirty
martini with vodka stir top well
Eric this this is really fun we could
talk for hours and hours and hours I
want to be respectful of your time and
so hopefully we'll get to meet in person
at some point certainly I'm in New York
often enough that I would really enjoy
that visit of course it will be a
pleasure is there anything before we
wrap up that you would and like people
listening to consider or try or ask
themselves or do do you have any ask of
the audience not really I mean I hope
that our conversation today will make
everyone think a little bit about his
lifestyle and about his definition of
happiness and about his impact in the
world and if we are done that which is
very ambitious I'm very happy and if we
haven't done it it's quite fine and
but I hope that our conversation is
first of all is be rational for
ourselves and and for others I think so
I think I think that if people listening
enjoyed this half as much as I did then
I think I think we're called and people
can certainly find you online to say
hello or thank you or to ask a question
on Instagram Twitter at Erick repair
it's ER I see are IP ERT and I apologize
from a terrible terrible French
pronunciation but I'm going to say it
like a Yankee and and then Facebook chef
Eric repair and the website this is
where my pronunciation is going to kill
me
LaBella then which is the le - ber na r
di n.com and eric it's been such a
pleasure i really appreciate you taking
the time I had a lot of fun great
pleasure and I'm honored to to be
talking to you and and your audience
thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity and hopefully I'll see you
in New York very soon oh yes now that's
a deal a hand to everybody listening we
mentioned a lot of books you mentioned a
lot of different resources different
types of meditation and so on you'll be
able to find links to everything we've
talked about in the show notes as always
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
for this episode and every other episode
and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec
founded by the genius Finn's who the
internet on fire and you may have heard
of their mushroom coffee which features
chaga and lion's mane which is taken
Silicon Valley by storm I use it pretty
much every day either that or the chaga
which is eat half a separate version and
I use both of these primarily for focus
and productivity they just get you going
let you up like a Christmas tree just
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic comport
slash Tim that's four sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c compote / Tim and use
the code
Tim TI m to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive
anyway if you are in the experimental
mindset I do not think you'll be
disappointed to try them out this
episode is brought to you by athletic
greens I get asked all the time if you
could only use one supplement what would
it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day as listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show you can receive 30% off of
your first order by visiting athletic
greens comm forward slash Tim that is a
great deal on one of my favorite
products and it covers my basics each
day it is part of my routine and it
leaves me with less to worry about if
for instance I have to skip a meal or
just can't get high quality meal
so check it out go to athletic greens
comm forward slash Tim and learn all
about it
[Music]
[Applause]